Welcome everybody. My name is
Todd Story. I'm the chief
communications officer for the
Clark County School District Um
what we'll do is we will start
this off with Trustee Evelyn
Garcia Morales then followed up
with Superintendent Doctor
Jesus Jara, principal Ryan
Lewis from Gerheim Elementary
School will then speak and
we'll turn it over to Chief
Blackeye and then following
Chief Blackeye, we'll hear from
District Attorney Steve
Wolfson. Thank you.
Good morning. I'm Evelyn Garcia
Morales, school board trustee,
the board's vice chair,
representing district C. As
everyone is aware, we've seen
an uptick in violence in some
schools and campuses. While
violence in schools is not a
new phenomenon. The level of
violence we are witnessing is
much worse. On behalf of the
board, we want to let you know
that we hear our community loud
and clear. While violence in
school is not, excuse me,
The school board and the
Superintendent and
Superintendent Jara are
committed to addressing these
issues swiftly to ensure that
our students and staff feel
safe to come to school and
education continues to be a top
priority. Disruptions and
violence by students. Will not
be tolerated. If you need help,
please reach out to a staff
member before resorting to
violence. Our staff is
available to support and assist
students. Please reach out and
utilize them if you are
struggling. Honorable personal
note, I want to share that as a
mom, an aunt of many students
in our school district, I know
how worrisome it can feel to
send our kids to school right
now. I'm going to encourage all
of our parents and guardians
and adults to check in with
their young people. Our
students need to know that we
care about their well-being.
I ask my son every day, what is
the best part of your day? What
was the most challenging part
of your day? And where did you
see kindness demonstrated by
your teachers or peers? These
questions really allow me to
look for subtle cues that
either had a really tough day
or he had a really great day.
Why don't don't I don't know
what it's like to be a young
person today And neither of us
and that nobody in this room
does really. I want, I know
that there we've all
experienced this collective
trauma. And are carrying our
own anxieties around it. This
is no different for our young
people. It's okay to feel sad.
It's okay to feel anxious. It's
okay to feel stressed out. As
adults, we get to model the
behaviors that we want for our
students, Display at home and
at school. And I implore our
parents and guardians and all
adults who interact with young
people to please talk to your
students. Engage their well
being everyday. Now, Doctor
Jarrell can explain the details
of what will be happening
across the district. Doctor
Jara. Thank you Vice President
Garcia Morales. Good morning.
The uptick in violence we're
seeing across the district.
Across the community and across
the nation cannot continue. Our
schools must be a safe place
for our children and for our
staff to learn and to teach. As
I stated a couple weeks ago at
the state of the schools,
student on student violence and
student adult violence that
have recently headlines in our
community and beyond. The
aggressive actions we see
mirror the increased violence
occurring in our communities
across the country. Our
children need their parents,
their guardians, their
community to support and
encourage them in healthy ways
of dealing with their emotions.
So talk to your children. Be
involved and show them your
care and support them. We know
that our kids are struggling
because of the stress,
anxieties, and isolation of the
pandemic. Put
it's not and will never be the
answer. We must view our
classmates, teachers, staff,
parents, administrators through
a lens of share hardships and
struggles to get through this.
Should students and adults
result to violence on our
campus we will remove them, and
hold them accountable according
to our discipline code of
conduct. Conversations have
been going on for a couple
weeks across district, our
staff. I can't thank enough our
principals who are here and
others. Our principal leads
that I have been in
conversations with to address
the needs of our students. So,
thank you for your leadership
as we have been dealing with
what's going on on our
campuses. Principles will work
with their staff to continue to
facilitate discussions and
remind our students of the
student code of conduct. So, I
give you some of the details.
If students violate the
students, the student code of
conduct, it will be clear what
consequences will be. There
will be responsible for. Any
physical altercation will be
added as a disciplinary
infraction. Fighting is a major
infraction on campus. Fighting
that results in significant
campus disruption will be a
recommended expulsion from
school. all major disciplinary
fractions will result in a
recommended expulsion with
removal from a comprehensive
school campus. With an
opportunity for reengagement,
battery to staff or students
resulting in a criminal
citation and distribution of
controlled substances. Students
recommended for expulsion for
any major disciplinary flagship
will be referred to the
following. Our academic
centers, Nevada Learning
Academy, the Lighthouse, and
Acceleration Academy. We must
continue to provide a free and
public education but it doesn't
have to be on our comprehensive
schools. Students committing
these infractions will require
re-engagement and
rehabilitation. We can't we
also know that zero tolerance
does not work. We have to take
care of our children, our
precious asset in this
community. So, we have to find
ways to reengage them involving
their parents and guardians in
their reengagement process.
monitoring their academic
progress, their positive
attendance,
completing the harbor
participating in restorative
practices and services and
anger management. Students
requiring re-engagement will
receive support from our
students, success coordinators,
from our counselors, our social
workers, our mental health
services, our parent
participation, and continue
this cross school
collaboration. So, starting
today, we will reconvene the
expulsion review board. Any
student possession in
possession of a firearm or any
dangerous weapon as defined by
NRS will be referred to the
expulsion review board align
with the district policy
regulation fifty-one fourteen
point two. We are also again
something that thanks the
leadership in our schools and
our facilities. We are going to
work and starting this month
our efforts in securing our
campuses, to make sure that we
provide a single point of
entry. We're also working with
our elementary school
principals and reset centers to
make sure that we teach our
kids and support them with
their emotional issues and
express so they can express
them properly. Reset spaces
will serve through de-escalate
and refocus behaviors and
engage in restorative
practices. We will continue our
professional learning All staff
will participate in
professional learning,
emergency procedures,
processes, aligned to our
student code of conduct with
our multi-tier system of
support. Additional information
will be also communicated to
our schools in the coming days.
Now, you'll hear from one of
our principals, mister Ryan
Lewis. President of the
principles Actually, the
administrators association, not
just principals. Thank you
Ryan. Good morning, everybody.
My name is Ryan Lewis. I am the
principal of Gerheim Elementary
School. Um I am not only
representing my school but my
colleagues here from
elementary, middle school, and
high school as the president of
our association. Um I wanted to
highlight that this year has
been a struggle. The struggle
is real. Uh we live it every
single day. Um and we wanted to
be solution based in moving
forward to helping our
community. Um we ign that we
have challenges. Um we
acknowledge that meeting these
challenges is not going to be
an easy task. Uh but we greatly
appreciate the opportunity to
collaborate with Doctor Jara
and the team to institute some
changes, some updates to meet
this need. Um it's going to
take some time to do this. Um
but with all of us as a
community we feel like we're up
to the task to make that
actually happen. Uh and that
collaborate process has really
been to be solution focused. Um
using community resource school
resources to make a difference
for our kids because we see it.
Um we know it's going to be
hard but it's worth it. It's
definitely worth it. Um and
with that moving forward, we
think we can make a difference.
Uh for more children in a in a
positive-based way which is
what we really need at this
point. Uh it's swaying away
from the negative and also
focusing on the positive and
what we can do to support
support these kids the last two
years. Uh we were just
mentioning before have has
taken a toll that's going to
take a couple more years even
to come out of. Um are really
struggling with issues that are
unprecedented. Um so, we have
to look at it from a different
lens to help make that happen.
Um so, I appreciate the efforts
that Doctor Jar and team are
making in collaboration with us
to making the the building
level safer, more productive,
and a positive outcomes for
them in the future. So, thank
you. Chief Black Eye.
Good morning. Mike Blackeye,
I'm the chief of Clark County
School District Police
Department. This school year,
so far, we've had 38 students
struck by vehicles on the way
to or from school. Several of
those have been fatal. We've
confiscated twenty5 firearms on
our campuses. That's. Inside
schools. We've had over a
thousand logged, a citations,
and arrest from our officers
since January of this year. One
ingredient to the School of
Violence that we've been seeing
is parents. Parents coming on
to our campuses committing acts
of violence to students, to
staff, and to each other. that
is added to the already high
number of student acts of
violence in our schools. As
you've, as you already know,
we've we've reported 3, 000
assaults and batteries and
fights since the start of this
school year and we're
approaching spring break. We're
approaching the end of the
school year and typically our
history shows that that
activity increases.
We're asking, urging parents to
talk to their students to their
children, ask them what's going
on in social media, check their
social media accounts. It seems
that since the pandemic
occurred, every single person
relied on social media and
everyone's been an expert and
and uploading content to you
know, show what they're doing,
what they're experiencing, and
that's what's happened this
school year. It's been a high
rate and as you know,
constantly, you're seeing
uploaded videos of fights and
incidents happening on our
campuses. Parents, please talk
to your students, talk to your
kids, find out what they're
doing, who they're talking to,
what what friends, what what
their friends are doing.
That'll help. Make sure that
they're portraying what you
believe your children are.
Portraying to you online. If
they have a different type of
persona that they're trying to
put forward out there. So we're
asking please talk to your
students. Talk to your kids. I
think that will help. Um also
talk to them about the
violence. We're we're big on
mental health, on addressing
those types of incidents.
Society is not stable right
now. You know, we have the the
war in Ukraine going on. We
just came out of a pandemic
where social isolation was
basically, all of us live
through that And our kids need
help And we're giving them all
the help that we can possibly
give them. But we need parents
to actually be involved in that
as well. Next, I'm going to
have
Steve Wilson
come up and talk
but before I say that,
Superintendent Jara talked
about not tolerating violent
acts in our schools and that'll
continue. So, with the help of
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
Department, Henderson Police
Department, and North Las Vegas
Police Department We're working
every day to ensure that the
schools remain safe places for
our kids to learn. Thank you.
Steve Wilson.
So, before I talk about a very
serious subject, I'd like to
make a quick observation.
Doctor Jara, thank you for
inviting me today. Number of
years ago, when I was in
school, I was always called on
last because my last name began
with a W. Some things don't
change. So, thank you for
allowing me to speak. The
district attorney's office
works in a collaborative
partnership with the school
district and the school police.
My lawyers are available
twenty-four/ 7 to respond to
schools and to answer
questions. But I can tell you
right now, school violence will
not be tolerated. And that
comes in many forms as been
mentioned. Students, staff,
parents. If there's violence on
or near a campus, it cannot be
tolerated There must be
consequences. Ironically, the
number of incidents hasn't
increased that much. the type
of violence has increased. The
number of violent incidences
are on the increase and that's
what's brought so much
attention to this problem. Uh
guns on campus, in my opinion,
there should be the severest of
consequences. Uh guns should
not be in the hands of
students, period. I can't say
it anymore. Simply, guns should
not be in the hands of
students, let alone being on a
school campus. When I went to
high school, if you had a beef
with somebody, the little
street fighter, whatever,
occurred off campus. I lived
down the street from a a
neighborhood park and that's
where students would go and and
duke it out a little and that
happened once in a while.
Today, it's happening literally
in the classroom, literally in
common areas of the classroom
and it's involving, like I
said, teachers and staffers and
parents. It it's really a
remarkable thing. What we're
experiencing now? As been said,
we're all listening to all of
you. We're listening to you
teachers to you police
officers, Doctor Jara, because
we want to work together to try
and change the culture which is
apparently in existence on
campus. So, as far as the
district attorney's office is
concerned, there will be
consequences for violence. Um
but at the same time, as been
mentioned, there are some
mental health issues going on,
the pandemic. Um in Ukraine. I
mean, you're right. Uh our kids
are listening to the news and
are aware of what's going on.
It's a stressful world we live
in. No doubt. Can you imagine
being a a 10 year old or a 12
year old or a 15 year old and
trying to understand the war in
Ukraine? And a pandemic where
you had to wear a mask to
school for months? Maybe not
even go to school. These are
tough, unique times. But we're
a great community. I've been in
this town for 41 and a half
years. My children went to
school here. So, we're working
together in a collaborative
effort with everybody to
hopefully make some positive
change. Thank you. Thank you
District Attorney Wilson. We'll
take questions if you got them
I have two two questions. Can
you give us an idea of the
scale of these changes? I mean,
you mentioned mandatory
expulsion. If this policy had
been in effect since August,
how many more expulsions are we
talking about? Is it dozens,
hundreds, thousands, assuming
no behavioral changes.
Uh thank you. Uh Mike Barton
for the record. Uh appreciate
the question, Victor. Uh I
can't predict what the number
would have been but just to
give some overview on the
expulsion and what the changes
at this point in time. There
are particular infractions
where they potentially used to
be discretionary in nature and
now, as we've said before
today, a recommended expulsion
infraction for particular
instances including major
fights on campus, campus
disruptions, but as far as
speculating how that may have
influenced the expulsion
numbers, it's hard to say,
Victor. And my second question
is for almost a decade and
certainly since the start of
Doctor Jarvis and your CCSD has
intentionally been trying to
discourage expulsion and
suspensions and as everyone
here knows violence has
increased as discipline has
dropped. Is this change and
acknowledgement of that
approach at all? So let me let
me so let me help clarify
because you you made two two
comments. Um for a decade I've
been here four years Victor. Um
so let's clarify the record. Um
and what I can tell you is
this. And I said it in my in my
my statement. The zero toler,
zero tolerance that we've had
experience in the past, not
here, but across the country in
public schools. Actually, when
I was a principal, that does
not work. What we are seeing
and the work that we have been
doing in collaboration with the
district attorney's office,
with the Department of Juvenile
Justice. It's really about
changing behavior. Right?
Changing, hold on. Let me, let
me, let me clarify a couple
things. Um, so it's about
changing the behavior of our
children. Cuz throwing them out
on the streets, it will be now
for our police and for the
metro and for the sheriff to
have to handle. We have to
provide an education. So the
work that we have been doing
not that it's not working. We
gotta think about it. So I got
here a year before the
pandemic. We started
professional development. We
are doubling down on the
professional development. Some
of the comments that I made is
really about reengagement. So
we as a as a school district is
we're doubling down on
providing the mental health
support for our students. We're
involving parents in this
conversation to reengage them
and give them the tools
necessary so they stay in
school. Now, does it have to be
in a comprehensive? I I I was
very clear. It doesn't have to
be in a comprehensive school.
Some students may need a
smaller setting And as we
provide a high-quality
instruction so is it working?
No, what I'm saying is that we
are going to improve the
systems because we have seen it
work but not as a whole when we
have three hundred and
sixty-six campuses. Thank you.
Hi, Doctor Um you know, we
haven't talked a lot about
restorative justice. Yeah. Um a
two-part question. What I'm
hearing that it's not being
implemented in some schools and
that it could be effective if
it is implemented. So, can you
comment on how we make sure
that it is in every school and
then, I'm just of that. Just
some of the changes and
discipline in the code of
conduct. Now, some severe. How
does that plan to and now in
what cases would restore
justice be used rather than the
expedition or suspension? So,
what I can tell you and and I
and I I just want to go back
and and thank our principals.
Um that when when mister Lewis
from the elementary and and
middle school, Todd Peterson
and also and Anthony and I know
that Tony Rail and and
Belinda's here and and my
conversations with the
principals, that's what, you
know, two weeks ago, I think it
was at our principal's meeting.
Um was that we need to do
better as a system on
professional development and
restorative practices. Cuz they
do work. Um so it's we are now
going to continue and as I say
double down is to make sure
that it's consistent across the
board. Um again it's it's it's
it's three years that we're at
this. You know for for for
folks to say that changing a
system that has occurred for
over 100 years and change it in
three years in the midst of a
pandemic. it's perfect,
absolutely, it's not perfect.
I'll be the first one to tell
you, it's not perfect. But we,
we can't just toss it
and not continue the work about
changing the behavior so our
children can learn. So, we're
doubling down so making sure
that all schools are providing
a consistent support system for
students around the restorative
practices. The second question
let Doctor Barton answer that
on on some of the specific
points, Doctor Barden. Uh thank
you, Doctor Jara. So, again,
the Superintendent made it very
clear, Restorative Justice work
takes time. Uh, there are
restorative practices that are
happening and trying to again,
identify a perpetrator
identifying how they can
correct that issue. But let's
be very clear. Uh, some
infractions that we've
mentioned today will not
involve restorative work. Um,
if there is an assault, there
there are restorative measures,
but could you repeat the second
part of your question? Yeah, I
want to ask because you talked
today about some, like an
impact an infraction used to be
discretionary. So, now, some of
the rules have changed in the
code of conduct. So, how does
that impact the sort of justice
and now, what would be such
restored justice? Certain
infractions require restorative
justice. However, if there is a
a battery on staff, battery on
student leading to a citation,
that will be a a recommended
expulsion along with
reengagement getting to the
root cause of the students
issue around mental health but
as far as restorative work
being involved in that kind of
a case for instance, may not
occur because honestly to sit
down a victim with a battery
incident with an adulter
student that's been battered to
sit down with a perpetrator,
not appropriate. So, but
definitely restorative justice
works but it works at those
other infractions where there
may be a minor physical
altercation or a minor fight.
Um the reality is that's where
restorative would work in
identifying through the
perpetrator really going deep
down inside on how they can
correct their behavior and do
in the future. Superintendent
Jara, you said we have to find
ways to reengage them,
involving their parents and
guardians in their reengagement
process. And as you mentioned,
you're looking to bolster
consequences for students who,
you know, commit any kinds of
acts. Yeah. Um, so something
that's come up in me talking to
people who work for CCSD, is it
kind of depends on the school
whether RPCs are being
conducted required here at
conferences. And these are what
teachers can say, hi, as Jones,
will you come to my classroom
and this is a required thing
for, you know, if their student
has. Right. Um you say you're
doubling down on this. So, does
that mean that there will be
more increased oversight on
ensuring that RPCs are
happening in each and every
school across the board? So,
when I say doubling down, I
think it's more of the what I'm
talking about some of these
other opportunity and courses
to involve at the at at some of
the infractions. When you're,
look, the first, the first, the
first level of, I would say,
support for families, is if
there's issues at home, if your
child is not come, not doing
homework, not, you know, that
doesn't want to go to school,
call your school. I mean, your
teacher, the counselor, I have
100% full confidence in our
leaders that they are here to
support our students. So, that
is your first level of defense.
Um, you know, as a parent,
having the trustee Garcia
Morales said it best. It's
having that conversation. If
you don't want to come to
you're not doing, don't want to
do homework, there's a reason.
Call the school, call the
teacher, the counselor, and
find out the why, right? So,
that's always going to be. Um I
used to say to my teachers, I
said, you know, you're if
you're seeing things that are
your your the students are
acting a little bit different
is make a phone call home. It
doesn't have to always be
negative. It's gotta be a way
to engage that family. So, that
is also where I'm going to be
an oversight in Manor.
Absolutely not. I have full
confidence in our principles
that they're going to continue
to provide that support at
school for our our parents.
Listen, you talk to them about
changes of your life too.
students begin in and we also
discussed some of the changes
that we've seen among parents.
Yeah. you make
Well, I I I can control the
305000 students. Um as far as
parents, I mean, I think our
chief was very clear. I mean,
what we're seeing are parents
coming on to our campuses. This
is where this is the what we're
all here. Uh as as as a
district, we need the community
support. Um we need if you have
an issue, even as adults, call
and get help. Um you you heard
the district attorney office.
You heard a police officers.
Their support here. Let us know
so then we're fine. But coming
on to a school, where children
can see that. It just continues
to exacerbate the problem and I
think that's where I would ask
for parents to you know, go
into the community and get the
support they need.
Superintendent. Uh I understand
a couple of years ago the
school district addressed the
issues of in the schools. Do
you know if any gang element is
connected to the the issues of
guns? Chief.
Well, that question can be
answered by Lieutenant Brian
Zink. We do have a a detective
assigned to Metro Gang Unit
that works directly with them
and investigates those
incidents. Uh we also are part
of the crime gun intelligence
center with the ATF and Metro
where each firearm that is
confiscated off school property
is then delivered and
immediately evaluated by that
group. So, we get an immediate
result on the activity
surrounding that that firearm.
Dad, can I go on further on?
They were talking about the
safety aspects and having the
one entry point. Um when will
that be implemented and then
you know, big discussion has
been metal detectors. Um are
there schools with metal
detectors and it's not being
looked at for others with as
well. So, as far as what single
point of entry, we we've gone
through the list and and you
know, these are things that are
principles that put in work
orders and and and we got the
list. We've got we're going to
streamline that and we're
going to fast track it. Our
facilities department will
start. We've, you know, have a
list of priority schools. We
are going to hopefully, you
know, the the big good news. I
don't know if they know yet but
we are going to fund it central
this is this is their our
campuses. It's a central
responsibility. So, we'll start
that work. Um you know, we're
within the next few few weeks,
right? It just started to go
addressing the one point of
entry and then also our
portables that are exposed. Um
is how do we then put some
fencing around our portables to
protect our kids. So, so that's
going to start within the next
couple weeks. As far as. Um
there's been a lot of
discussion about metal
detectors. Do you need? So, we
do we we have okay. So, I
want to be very clear and and
I'll let the experts. I'm not
the expert, our our police
department is the expert. Um on
on metal detectors and we've
had I've been in other places
where experts have come in and
metal detectors you know it's
it's it's a challenge to get
three thousand, 4, 000 kids to
school on time. We, the metal
detectors that we do have, we
use them for football games but
that is not the answer for this
right now. Um we we will not be
using metal detectors to walk
in. This is not about this is
not about hardening our
schools. Um our schools need to
be inviting in in a in a safe
space for our children we do
have a different strategy. We
do random searches. Uh we have
we've had doubled I would say
our canine you know that come
in into our and and do random
searches across the entire our
schools. Randomly selected. Um
and we do some of those random
searches not only with Knine
but then also within our our
school leaders. So that and and
and maybe the chief can speak
to that but that seemed to, you
know, when we were doing that
before COVID, we saw a decrease
in in the number of guns that
we found. So, that is the
strategy that a superintendent
we're going to continue doing.
So, basically, we are, we're
looking at our, at our
facilities because we have open
campuses. Uh I mean, we have I
think principal Kevin McMarlan
is here from Arborview. They're
open campuses. are beautiful
campuses but it's just you
there's too many kids coming in
and out and and it makes it
that more of a challenge. So,
we're going to then put some
put some systems and and
fencing and and not the the
head of the facilities here but
we're going to find ways to
make sure that we we limit all
the entry points. So then all
the kids come into a one
campus. Uh we do have we have a
list of schools that had that
are wide open. We have some
already that are in that point.
So we're looking at that list
and we're going to expedite the
process there. you elaborate
more on the explosion review,
Florida who would be made up by
and what exactly are they going
to do? Uh thank you for the
question. Um so the Expulsion
Review Board is is set in
policy and it's comprised of
trustees. Trustees typically
haven't been involved in the
due process hearing panels but
the expulsion review board has
trustees as members, board of
school trustees, retired
administrators with knowledge
about disciplinary practices.
Um and they hear cases and
that's where determinations are
made. There are multiple levels
of due process for students in
the district that lead up to
review board but ultimately
with the firearms, we're going
directly to that expulsion
review board because of the
serious nature of those
infractions.
completely be restoring some
programming that should happen
to years such as behavioral
school and being positioned.
behavior school in Roman. Uh
thank you for the question. Uh
again, Mike Barton for the
record. Uh we we have we have
seats available at academic
centers as we call them,
behavior schools. Um, we've had
a reduction in the number of
behavior schools over the last
several years. Um, as far as
the dean question, we've
pivoted that role to a
different position in the
district where it's more of a
less punitive role but they're
still involved in discipline
but again, they're interacting
with counselors, mental health
professionals to ensure that
we're getting to the root cause
of behaviors and that was a
change that we made three years
ago with the pivot of that
dean's position. That one
That's correct. Yes. We don't
intend to reinstate deans at
this time. This role is a
relatively new role but again,
it's focused on getting to the
antecedent or the root cause of
behaviors and and we again,
we're training those folks to
be around discipline but also
how do we work with families,
students, teachers to promote a
safe learning environment. And
that the behavioral schools
will maintain what you have
right now. We don't of course
be having to up open up more
spaces or reopen Great
question. We don't. We we've we
view with what we've announced
today. We have the academic
centers or behavior schools
that will be utilized for
infractions. However, we also
discussed earlier the Nevada
Learning Academy where there
are options online. And there
will be services for
reengagement provided even with
those opportunities that are
temporary disciplinary
placements. Superintendent. Um
if you can talk a little bit
about just the frustration in
general for the school
district. You know, how do we
get here And moving forward,
how do you also, what message
do you have for your staff to
lift up the crowd? Yeah. So,
it's a great question. Well, I
I couldn't predict the pandemic
in my years of study. I I never
predicted that we would be in
this situation. It's and and I
never predicted that we'd be a
at this place. Um where we are
today. Um that Something and
and and I, you know, my
principals who are here and and
schools and staff it is
frustrating. Um it's it's it's
not it's the hardest thing I've
ever done in my career. Leading
a school district through a
world pandemic that the entire
world shut down, the economy.
Um when we close schools, I
thought it was going to be 2
weeks. and we're going to be
back and and reopen schools.
Then, it came, you know,
through months and months So,
when we open, we were all
excited. I said, March 1st of
last year, when we saw our
children back in school for the
hybrid, it was the best day
that I've experienced. Um
coming back seeing kids in
school, seeing our teachers. Um
and our principles. Giving it
all. Um and also opening up a
school system as big as we are
Um I'm proud of the work that
we've done with all our
bargaining units. I said this
last night because their school
systems that open and shut down
and they're in current lawsuits
with their unions. Our unions
stepped up. Up and said we're
going to do this safely for our
staff. But get they understood
how critical our kids needed to
be in school. How important
that was. And then Um we opened
up and and and we saw I would
tell you, we saw our kids
struggle because they were home
and isolated. They were on
computers. Um you know, that
and and and my my colleagues
who are here, the principals
said that to me. We've never
seen some other behavior where
kids were at home unsupervised
in some cases because parents
had to work. Um so, I be more
proud of as frustrated as I am
and I have been, I couldn't be
more proud of working with the
leaders to find solutions. Um
as they came in and said, boss,
soup, we get, we, we're we're
seeing this and how do we
address it and coming together.
So, I ask our our teachers, our
staff, our 42, 000 employees, I
thank them for their work. You
know, I'm going to tell little
Last last week, I was actually
Sunday and somebody said, you
know, we we did and celebrated.
Nurses, we celebrated everybody
out in the community. Well, how
about celebrating our
educators? We never closed
down. We shifted to a distance
that. These folks still
delivered education. But just
from home. for the fifth
largest school district in the
country to do that is
remarkable.
Um so, I just say to this
community celebrate our
educators because when this
school system closed down and
this community closed down, we
served over 21 million meals To
this community and they're
tired. But they're coming in
and showing up. Those who are
coming in. So, there is a level
of frustration but you know
what? You can't you you you
can't give up. because our kids
need to be educated. So, tell
the teachers that I hear them
and this is why we're all here.
Um our our parents be part of
the solution. So, we can help
our kids get to where they need
to be.
First one is, can you just
clear about a little bit more
discussion process? So, I need
some all types of Doctor
Barton.
Thank you, Superintendent. Uh
thank you for the question. So,
the the expulsion
recommendations will be around
the campus disruption. If a
fight is determined to be a
major, major fight in or a
student that's been involved in
multiple fights or attempts to
try to bring others on campus
to fight that will be deemed a
campus disruption and again, as
stated before, will be a
recommended expulsion
recommendation. Uh fights,
typically are are are major and
those could lead to a referral
to a academic center as we
described. Uh physical which is
being added to the code of
conduct is more for minor
infractions but the reason for
the change in the code of
conduct swiftly right now was
again to highlight that campus
disruption where those major
fights occur will lead to a
discretionary expulsion
recommendation. Is that
settled? Does it actually reach
out to me CCSD getting the
publishing and also just there
was an opportunity. with this
violence. Is that true? You
guys are also seeing among some
of your educators. Yourselves.
Our our focus is our obviously
our staff, our employees, Their
safety is paramount along with
our students. So as far as
talking to students, talking to
our employees, I think that,
you know, we've had several
meetings with student groups.
Students have seen this this
uptick in violent acts and so
what we've learned is that
there's this lower level of
connectedness on campuses and
again, this is all related to
what the Superintendent
described, our pandemic, school
closures. So, how are we
building bridges back on our
communities to make sure that
students feel connected to
those staff that you mentioned.
So, we're working really hard
to ensure that A number one,
our schools feel safe for
students and our staff. Thank
you, everybody.